hello and welcome to the chicky science
show so
i took a little bit of time off this
week which left last time for a video
so i thought i'd talk about something
simple and that i know quite a lot about
and you know kind of keep it light so in
this video
we're going to address the multifaceted
functions of the cellular tumor antigen
p-53 in response to cellular insults and
pre-new plastic tissues and how it is
mediated at both a transcriptional and
post-transcriptional level
i'm joking um or am i
but in all seriousness whilst i do put
in many waking hours into this channel
i am also doing a phd on the world's
coolest protein
oh hang on i'm not quite sure what
happened to my voice there
let me try again on the world's coolest
protein
okay that didn't work but because this
is so cool
it's been well studied and while trying
to keep up with literature
whilst conducting experiments and trying
to analyze data takes a lot
of time time which i evidently have
sparingly
so partly for my own benefit and also
because there has been some interest in
what i actually do
i thought in this video i'd cover some
interesting focus points on this protein
an unaddressed questions so where is the
p53 feels at
well to really understand that question
you first need to know what p53 actually
is
and well it's a protein the world's
coolest protein
but this protein is a transcription
factor so what that means is that it can
bind to dna
and activate the expression of different
genes
and so p53 doesn't just do this all the
time it only seems to do this when it's
activated in response to different
stresses
so what happens usually is that inner
cell p53 gets expressed
but then it gets degraded and this is
because of a protein known as
mdm2 it tags p53 for degradation
and so in normal unstressed conditions
the levels of p53 are quite low in a
cell
however when there's stress whether it's
reactive oxygen species
expression of an oncogene dna damage
extreme hypoxic conditions these all
cause stabilization
of p53 and so when p53 is stabilized
it can activate these different genes
and p53 does this by binding to its
so-called p53 response element
and so it's just a consensus sequence on
dna
that the dna binding domain of p53
recognizes and combine two
and then it brings in the
transcriptional machinery to upregulate
these different genes
the interesting thing is that p53 seems
to be a kind of
stress dependent decision transcription
factor
basically it seems to mediate the
decision between a variety of different
responses to cellular stress
and so these different responses include
the induction of cell cycle arrest
cell death most notably apoptosis
cellulosin essence dna repair and
metabolic changes
and cellular differentiation and so
these mechanisms are not necessarily
mutually exclusive
as the immediate action of p53 most
often seems to be a cell cycle arrest
and the cell cycle arrest is to help
tell the cell stop
guys there's a problem we need to fix it
and it can help activate dna repair
in regions of damage and so if that
damage is repaired the idea is that the
cell then goes back to normal and if
it's not repaired and the damage is more
severe or it just keeps on building
it then decides to go into cell death or
it could enter cellulose in essence and
have a variety of other changes and so
some of the key questions
are how is p53 mediating these different
downstream responses
and well yeah that's a pretty good
question and there's been a lot of work
that has already tried to
to evaluate this in fact i just finished
reading a nice review article that
summarized
the life versus death decision of p53
but you might be wondering why should we
really care about how
p53 coordinates this decision between
cell
death versus cell survival which is
selena senescence
whereby the cell is still alive it's
just arrested permanently
and secretes all these inflammatory
factors
well there's actually several reasons
one it's just interesting to understand
the molecular underpinnings because
you can then highlight specific pathways
or protein targets that can be
therapeutically
targeted to manipulate this decision
process
for example if you understood how it was
coordinating
apoptosis over senescence you could you
might be able to therapeutically cause
it to go one way or the other and in
fact this has already been done for
example in the use of analytics
which are drugs that can selectively
kill senescent cells
and this is because as i've just been
saying senescent cells
seem to upregulate genes that promote
pro-survival
instead of apoptosis and so there was
the rationale that if you can acutely
activate
p53 in these senescent cells it would
upregulate apoptosis
and cause cellular death and at least
two less analytic strategies have
exploited this
the first one is the development of
drugs that could inhibit
the interaction between p53 and mdm2
remember mdm2 being that the grader of
p33
and that can be seen in ubxo101 which
well albeit had a little bit of a
failure last year but
was trying to use that strategy to
enhance the lysis
of those senescent cells an alternative
strategy
used this cell penetrating peptides that
inhibited an interaction between p53 and
a protein
known as foxo4 and by inhibiting this
interaction it causes the relocalization
of p53 from the nucleus into the
cytoplasm
and this localization can alter p53's
function that can cause apoptosis
and it was nicely shown in this 2017
study that
application of this foxo4 peptide
could restore fitness hair density and
renal function
in naturally aged mice so further
understanding this decision process of
p53 between
apoptosis and cellulosin essence could
definitely aid the discovery of new
synalytic approaches
but irrespective of whether apoptosis or
cellulosin essence is induced both of
these responses could be seen as
tumor-suppressive mechanisms
because they stop a damaged cell from
further replicating
and potentially causing tumor
geneticists and so for these reasons
p53 is often referred to as a tumor
suppressor
and so therefore it may not be
surprising to hear that mutations
in the gene encoding p53 are the most
common event in human cancers
and out of these different mutations in
p53 the most common are so-called
missense mutations and these are most
frequent in the dna binding domain of
p53
and so a missense mutation refers to the
fact that the mutation
changes the amino acid from one to
another and so
a full full-length p53 protein is
generated
it just has a single amino acid
substitution
but because it's in the dna binding
domain it seems to reduce the
ability of p53 to actually bind dna
as a consequence of this miscentric
mutation is often just called
losser function but these missense
mutations are more interesting than that
because they can also have so-called
dominant negative effects
whereby if you've got a missense mutant
p53 nacelle
at the same time as a wild type a normal
functioning copy of p53
it can form these heteroattachments
whereby the mutants can antagonize the
ability of the wild type
normal copy to bind dna but even more
interestingly
there's also so-called gain of function
properties
allocated to these missense mutants or
p53
whereby they seem to be doing all sorts
of other things that's a normal
wild-type copy of p53 wouldn't do
and so the reason i told you all this is
because as much as i love p53
i actually study its evil non-identical
twin these missense mutations
and um how they can implicate the
function of wild type p53
especially in the early stages of
temogenesis
say before there's even a gmo and i mean
that's in itself
sounds a little bit challenging because
finding a model
for pre-cancer is quite hard because
well the tumor hasn't occurred yet
anyway one way i can try to explore this
implication of mutant p53 is by studying
cellulosin essence which is
pretty much what i'm trying to do my
project in the simplest times
and it kind of does change on a monthly
basis
anyway so yeah that's just a general
area of my interest
i don't it's important for me not to
kind of like overhype my work
and say it's like the most important
thing in the world because
well i don't know
but it does seem to be the case that at
least one of your cells in your body
does have
a mutated alloy of p53
and therefore it's interesting to
understand how it could further cause
different diseases
obviously as a cancer researcher i'm
going to talk about it from a cancer
perspective
but p53 mutations have also been
implicated
in different age-associated diseases
such as fibrosis and
and innate immunity and so um
it's kind of like opening pandora's box
but at the moment we kind of understand
i'm using the p53 batter in the cancer
context
as in tumor tissues there seems to be
the stabilization of mutant p53
and so some kind of cool work is being
done to try and understand
whether drugs can be used to convert
mutant p53 into the wild type copy
and therefore have high protein
abundance of wild type p53 which could
then induce apoptosis
specifically in tumor cells and that
drug is primer one
and so this table you can see here just
shows a variety of different mechanisms
those are being researched to reduce the
abundance of mutant p53
in hope that it could reduce the
tumorogenic properties of these mutated
cells
and so it's interesting to note that on
this list of compounds it also includes
mtor inhibitors and metformin which
are both obviously linked with longevity
and lifespan enhancements
and so it could be questioned as to
whether some of the benefits seen in
these studies
in terms of reducing cancer incidents in
these different mouse models
by treating them with different
longevity supplements could be due to
reducing the ability of mutant p53 to
accumulate themselves and cause
mayhem but um honestly at the moment i
think
there's just so a lot to be explored in
this area which makes it very
interesting to study
um but also very complicated just due to
the nature of p53
and it's a ability to be involved in
every single cellular process
well maybe not every single process but
a lot of them
um but it makes it fun and i enjoy
studying at
so anyway i hope you've enjoyed this i
guess a little bit different video
insight into what it is i get up to in
the research lab
and learnt more about the world's
coolest protein
anyway um yeah i hope you found
something and thank you to my patreon
supporters and
thank you for listening